Mobile apps are changing the world!
Android was introduced by Google in 2007 and is the most popular
smartphone operating system on the planet today!
And now  Android Development is Kotlin-First!
And now you can learn directly from Google professionals  in the new
Android Kotlin Developer Nanodegree Program from Udacity!
The Nanodegree program is built by industry and for industry!
Because Udacity doesn’t just teach you a programming language -
we give you all the skills needed to land a job!
The program prepares students for a career as professional Android Kotlin Developer,
Anyone starting a new project, should write it in Kotlin;
because code written in Kotlin means much less code! Less code to type, test, and maintain!
You’ll learn by developing real world, hands-on projects
including an advanced Android application that utilizes Google Maps
to provide key location-based updates!
Master Kotlin-first Android development
and get equipped to build the next industry-defining killer app
for the world’s most-used mobile platform!
Enroll in the new Android Kotlin Developer Nanodegree Program today!